doors wide open for business you know  you want to come in and help us rebuild  our economy think local be local buy  local  don't buy from strangers why from  neighbors it's about all of us now we've  done our bit to fit in the curb incur  it's time to fix our economy hello let's  keep the community spirit going remember  how good it felt during the lockdown out  in the belt walking around you seen TD  bees in the windows getting a waiver a  smile now it's time to pay it forward  don't boys from strangers buy from  neighbors remember the business owners  who made donations to your school sports  raffles well made cheese rolls for the  school sports trips and now it's time to  say things and the same thanks pingu  filer be local  [Music]  do it